adriana is with us in San Antonio Texas
hi Andrea how are you hi I'm good how
are you better than I deserve what's up
well my husband he's in prison right now
and he'll be were getting released in
this this August of this year and were
he misses to your show and he me and him
are wondering like how are we gonna
start fresh like he's gonna have no job
when he comes out anything and we're
trying to kind of turning to use to help
us out here um what's he in prison for
for growing weed okay so was a felony uh
no misdemeanor weed but okay all right
so he's uh he's not got a felony
conviction then yeah yes he does for a
previous previous conviction but yet so
this he is a convicted felon under what
you think well I guess the first part of
starting your life over would be to
course-correct
on the mistakes that have ruined your
life would that be right correct and so
is he going to get out of the weed
business yes he wants to get into
farming as fart like animals I was in
farming already so he knows what he's
doing already okay so he's going to go
into the wants to go into livestock yes
okay and so he's done with the felony
drug stuff that's got this and that's
messed up his life right yes yes because
that's an important part here because
really you can't there's no point in and
it really does hamper the rebuilding of
your life if you're building it on you
know a bad foundation that's gonna
that's going to cause it to crumble
again you know what I'm saying okay so
we got to have a career track that a
felon can have and that does limit you
somewhat but it doesn't it doesn't keep
you from winning you can still go in
once you decide you're going to be
somebody and so he wants to go into
farming and but I assume you don't own a
farm right right not right now time and
so my guess is he would probably end up
working to start with as
Ranch Hand in right um actually he went
he wants to go into more of the nursery
as well likes honest on the side nursery
heat he's a big green thumb so it's not
just the weed that's like like it's not
just that it's just the whole growing
tree that here okay good that's good
alright well I think what you've got to
do is just take those that you know this
this desire to be in agriculture and his
abilities their passions for that and
say alright how can I do that in a way
that's honest legal and in a way that
makes money for my family and you've got
to start kind of analyzing that and
develop almost a business plan or a
career track I think that's a really
good thing to do and then once we've got
some money coming in then then of course
we start applying the principles of
handling money that we teach here on the
show of getting out of debt and being on
a budget and saving money first for
emergencies and later for purchases of
things and just being willing to go
slowly with the income side of things so
probably not taking over now I'm
assuming I'm assuming you work right
correct okay and what do you make a year
oh I before before we had our daughter I
was I was a server at a restaurant so my
income was a little up and down however
I don't work right now because of the
situation in my my parents have agreed
to help me until he comes out of this
year so you're staying with your parents
and you don't work right right not right
now right yes right now yes because my
daughter has there's no way for me to
pay it for them to pay for daycare and
and have me at we work so that we've
agreed to have a have me stay with her
so how old are you I'm 22 how old is he
he is 30 okay well I would just start
with saying okay both of you have to lay
out some good careers and you need to
start looking at each area of your life
and reviewing those and starting to set
some goals and getting better so one
area is your marriage one area is your
parenting one area is your careers one
area is your physical body and how you
take care of it but
of you one area is your spiritual walk
and so I good way to kind of get all of
those things gathered up and to get some
good people speaking into you and your
husband's life and kind of give you
direction on all that is to make sure
you're plugged into a good local church
so far the series of decisions you all
have made have been really destructive
for you exactly exactly so we got to
change some of your decisions to get you
back on the track so I'm going to do
this I want to send you a copy of a book
called start I think I think it'll help
you and I'm also going to have Kelly
sign you guys up for August for
Financial Peace University when he gets
out I want you to go I want you to go
through the class it's nine weeks long
on how to handle money but the big
challenge between now and then and I
don't know if he's in a jail situation
rather than a federal or a state prison
they may allow a hardback book in if
they do then you can give him a copy of
this book when I get it to you okay and
some places only allow softback books we
do a lot of work with prisons and so but
the anyway they get that book in there
because I want him to really begin to
lay out a track of exactly what he's
going to do to create income yeah it has
to go beyond just this idea of I like
growing things or I like working with
animals he has laid out budgets the
possible numbers and he's tried so what
type of centrally hang of doing to make
money then tell me what he's doing he
like like he started with the farm with
the farming idea and then he also where
is he farming he didn't have a farm no
this is either his parents have them out
in West Texas there's a lot of there's a
land out there for him too they have
land out there for him to speak in his
work so they have he has a small start
in out in West Texas question I gotta
move you got to move to West Texas is he
allowed to do that with parole and all
yes yes sir okay good and so you got to
move out there and and then we're gonna
do something he's got some crops he
wants to plant exactly let's start with
just the even just
small livestock like chickens and oh
that's fun
goats and things like that just start
small nothing don't start into that very
don't jump into it you know that you
don't need to buy a $200,000 tractor you
had many money yet so yeah yeah that's
exactly the thing to do
okay well then he's ahead of the curve
that sounds good the trick is this you
also need to be willing to work some
part-time stuff to get some income
coming in while we're waiting on a crop
to come in or waiting on those chickens
to lay some eggs or whatever it is we're
doing so hold on Kelly will pick up and
we'll get you signed up for financial
piece and we'll get you a copy of the
book start
you